there's no one who's stepping up with a
clear interest in getting a trade
accomplished for julio jones that
wouldn't be the problem for the packers
if they wanted to trade aaron rodgers
they would be teams that would be ready
to go they'd be ready to bid and as i've
said before and chris you agree with me
they're never going to get more than
they would get right now for aaron
rodgers this is the time to strike if
you're going to trade him but the
packers continue to dig in their heels
and rogers as we spent time breaking
down yesterday his appearance on
sportscenter the things he said about
the people persons paper people here's
matt leflore the one person
in management that aaron rodgers doesn't
hate
addressing the aaron rodgers comments
from monday's sports center during a
tuesday press conference let's hear from
coach leflore
i'm guessing i listened to aaron
yesterday um you kind of hinted that in
his opinion there's a people problem in
your organization how do you view that
yeah
i thought just like aaron said that was
a heck of a tribute to kenny mayne and
it was pretty cool that he went on there
for him and you know growing up
kenny was
he was definitely one of my favorites
watching on sportscenter hesitance to be
back is the people issue that he
referred to last night how how do you go
about
fixing that as an organization so that
he does return
well i think we're you know like you
mentioned
aaron definitely knows how we feel about
him um you know how
how he's such an important part to our
football team such an important part to
our organization and you know we're just
going to continue to try to
work through this and hopefully can get
them back in the building at some point
you know i'd like to get inside of matt
lafleur's brain because i think one of
the primary thoughts at the front of
what is that the frontal lobes cerebral
cortex
somewhere in there he's got to be
thinking i've gone 26 and six and i
gotta deal with this
stuff oops almost that was close that
was as close as we've ever gotten i've
done i am i'm no no you've said it what
do you mean it's closest we've ever gone
talking about you
we know we're talking about you you
you're a different gay you're a
different ball game you're in a
different league okay yes i'm in the
minor leagues you're in the majors
so
so uh yeah i mean the guy's 26 and six
he's come in and two years ago he
threaded the needle with the whole
audible thing the the controversy that
aaron rodgers i believe specifically
engineered through mike silver fellow
cow graduate engineered through that
interview that silver did sure putting
the issue front and center so it could
be hashed out rogers knew where this was
going wait a minute you're going to get
two plays in the huddle and that's
that's it and i have to pick one of the
two at the line of scrimmage based upon
the defense and i have no discretion as
to what to do beyond that and i can't
change the play are you kidding me
that's how we're gonna do this no that's
not how we're gonna do this and he won
yeah and
leflore was smart to let him win right
26-6 213 in three seasons two nfc
championships and he's the one who's
thrown in the middle he's caught in the
crossfire between rogers and the front
office and he's the one that's got to
stand up there and answer the questions
the day after roger says what he says
right look i i've said this before as it
relates to teammates
roger's attitude his behavior his
demeanor his wishes justified as they
may be they put others in a tough spot
yes they do he's put his head coach in a
very tough spot he he has i you know
again it's not you're right i mean ever
since matt leflore has gotten there
every offseason it's been dealing with
drama
and he's not comfortable with it you
could see right there and you know
knowing matt a little bit and being
around him before that's this is not the
kind of stuff he wants to do he kind of
wants to just be inconspicuous and coach
the football team
and have his relationship with his guys
that way but yeah
rogers
his situation his actions everything
like that yes are making it hard on the
football team there's no doubt about
that
but mike but
but
anybody with a pulse paying attention to
nfl football could have told you this is
what the hell was going to happen when
you draft a quarterback in the first
round and your team is in the super bowl
window and the end for your quarterback
is nowhere near in sight
so i will say once again i don't love
all the things that aaron rodgers is
doing
but the jump off point for all these
problems is still green bay and you and
i both know we could have predicted this
was going to happen when they drafted
jordan love on the next day of the show
and talked about did yeah exactly so
that's that's where matt leflore he's
probably going damn i wish aaron would
come here and take some of the pressure
off me but he can also walk upstairs and
go damn you two put a lot of damn
pressure on me you two as in guten coos
and mark murphy and that's where it's
you know a tough tough call there
let me tell you something i'm going to
go back yeah two years ago
when matt leflore emerged as a surprise
candidate to stand in the shoes
previously filled by the likes of vince
lombardi
mike holmgren
that's enough those two guys fiery
mccartney super bowl
mike mccarthy too okay but but but i'm
talking about
i know and mccarthy the guys that we
know are
type double a positive my way or the
highway head coaches
i
matt lafleur has done enough
that if he was wired a different way
from a personality standpoint there are
other coaches who would use that
to leverage more power and influence for
himself
and i think one of the reasons they
picked matt lafleur when it was mark
murphy and brian gooda coons deciding
who we're going to hire for this job
i think they're looking for a
personality type where they don't have
to worry about the guy having success
and trying to take over i agree because
at some point you know what matt
laflore's got to try to take over at
some point matt lafleur's got to go to
those guys and say what in the hell are
you doing to me i've given you 26 wins
in 32 regular season games and you have
continued to put me in a difficult spot
with the best player in the nfl and you
won't fix it and i'm caught in the
middle of it and i don't appreciate it
and curse word curse word curse word
right yourself
i you know and and i just don't think
lafleur's wired to do that and i think
it's one of the reasons why they hired
him because they predicted he wouldn't
upset the apple cart on behalf of aaron
rodgers if and when they hatched this
plan to go out and draft his replacement
and rogers wasn't happy about it
lafleur's not going to join forces with
rogers where other coaches
and we know who they are would be
tempted to say hey goody hey murphy what
the hell are you guys doing
and and and then that coach begins a
campaign with the fan base with the
board of directors with the executive
committee to try to force them to put
pressure on the guys who are keeping the
coach from having the best possible
chance he can have to build a legacy in
greenback yeah no mike i don't disagree
with anything you said i mean yeah i
mean that matt lafleur is not that type
of guy there's no doubt i don't doubt
that that is part of the reason you know
they they got involved it's it's i think
it's one of the things they look for in
green bay they look for coaches
really ever since i've been a teenager
it feels like guys that they feel like
they won't step on the shoes of the
front office
not homegrown well holmgren wanted it
but that's ultimately right what what
led him to get the hell out of there and
go to seattle so he could call the shots
because there was that little issue then
and you know as we know green bay
they've their great scouting department
they are a great front office for what
they've done this long to be this
relevant all these years there is a real
process and beauty to what they do and
you know those people have continued
throughout that organization most of
people in that front office have grown
up and got all their you know pelts on
their horse in that organization so
they've been taught to run it that way
and which leads to you to hire coaches
like you're talking about matt lafleur
which i'm with you i think you're you're
right to a degree that is right why they
hired him
the brian goodkoon situation isn't the
cause of the aaron rodgers consternation
it's a symptom of a structure that has
been in place for decades right green
bay and that's why this whole idea that
it's about the people is so ludicrous
you have at the core of the packers
organization a brain trust that runs the
show without input from anyone else
without input from the coaching staff
definitely without input from the
players without input from the fans
without input from the media they know
what works and they're the ones calling
the shots and that's what aaron rodgers
is ultimately pissed off about and
that's what matt lafleur
is incapable of fighting against and
that's why we are where we are yeah
exactly right i mean and you know to
what you're saying with the organization
and you know the process you know
talking about guten coost and all those
type of things you're right that's
exactly right it's what's made them
really good they're you know i mean
really ever since brett favre it's been
very few years that we can really think
of where green bay hasn't been at least
relevant in a playoff contending type
football team and that's great but where
the formula that we talk about in their
front office that's made them
consistently good is awesome the other
thing i would say is like you heard me
say a few weeks ago
you also have to gauge every now and
then go wait wait this is our formula
that's made us good
but
we we got brett favre aaron rodgers and
we're really good and let's go all in it
could it handicaps them at times because
of the structure they're always trying
to follow at least in my opinion
the formula levels out allowed them to
be consistently good since bob harlan
and ron wolfe joined forces because it
was 20 years of crapola as you would say
for the packers from lombardy until
until ron wolf got there but that
formula allows them to be consistently
good has pres prevented them from being
as great that's the way to say it
exactly right you're right thank you for
cleaning up my english language speaking
that's not that good but yes that's
exactly the saying is the saying is
don't let perfect be the enemy of the
good for the packers good has been the
enemy of perfect you're right exactly
right i think they've dropped the ball
from that sense a little bit throughout
the favre and roger jared aware okay
let's abandon you know like you're
saying the normal formula and go all in
or make this move that we usually don't
make because we're really close and this
gets us over the hump and you know yes
you can you can praise all the
consistency and all the good and
everything like that but you can also
sit here and realistically say you had
two of what i look at as the five or six
greatest quarterbacks ever and you've
only won a super bowl each with either
one and i think that's a problem too you
know when i look at it that way
all right matt lafleur also addressed
the quarterback who is now entering year
two who at some point presumably will be
the starting quarterback of the packers
jordan love here's leflore talking about
love
i think jordan is definitely you can
tell he put some work in in this
offseason on his own i think the ball
is really jumping out of his hands well
right now and you know it's
day two of otas and
you know all we've really done is thrown
routes on air we had some seven on seven
but you guys could see the the team
periods they're not full speed so
um
you know
we're excited about just some of the
progress we've seen with them but
certainly there's a there's a long way
to go there
you know running back aaron jones also
said that love looks a lot more
comfortable especially when it comes to
taking command of the huddle he's going
to continue to grow and i'm happy to be
here working with him jones said jones
also said that that aaron rodgers didn't
say anything to him about possibly not
being there and jones would have still
resigned this is home i love it here so
uh aaron jones recognizing the very real
possibility that it will be jordan love
maybe this year maybe next year but at
some point he'll be working with love
they like what they see so far and they
got to get this guy ready that's right
this is his opportunity there's a point
you made the other day aaron rodgers is
yielding voluntarily to jordan love the
opportunity to come in and grow into the
role yeah grow into the roll get reps
get better right and you know the the
the packers players and the coaches they
got no choice they got to support this
guy they got it they need him i mean
again we don't know what the hell aaron
rodgers is going to do and as we've
talked about a lot i mean yes he is the
type of guy that might just go the hell
with it i'm not playing this year i
don't like you guys it's about the
people and you screwed over your best
people and me so yeah
they they need him ready for just in
case
that scenario happens this year
and
of course they need to put the pressure
on jordan love and need growth there
because ultimately i think we all
believe and i think they got to even
believe even if aaron rodgers comes back
this year
this is it so love's got to take over
after this and that's why this is an
important time for his growth and
getting better and it's good to hear
that there there has been some
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports